the entitlement The Virtue signaling the
hypocrisy all of it is encapsulated in
these two and the untouchability right
if I mean you found out right if you say
something that crosses them and yes you
hurt their feelings and they're very and
they believe they have a right to get
people removed from their jobs if they
don't agree with everything they're
saying well and I think it's a lie I
think the public reaction to them is so
heartening because they really are quite
terrible I mean I'm watching this as an
American I have no dog in this
particular fight but I gotta say they're
just they're just the worst in the the I
actually read Prince Harry's awful
Memoir and uh the the number of things
that are obviously not true yeah and the
absolute self-delusion and arrogant
self-delusion intrusion into his own
family's life quoting family members
from funerals and stuff far more
intrusive than anything he wants privacy
but he has very specific memories of
using particular facial cream on I
didn't know we're I mean I'm American we
don't use the word Dodger in in my
country so I have no idea